the libs indicted Trump again
four more times to be precise all over
[Music]
January 6th the worst day in the history
of this or any Republic
now given the number of times that
they've done this already and are sure
to do it again in the future this would
not even be a headline news story save
for the unfortunate fact that this case
is being tried in Washington D.C a town
far less favorable to Trump than Florida
where the last charges are scheduled to
be tried the other thing that makes this
trial a little bit more newsworthy than
the usual Democrat attacks against Trump
is that one of the punishments for the
charges in this case is death I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with code Knowles
Canada wlas go to goodranchers.com use
code Knowles today
I want to get to the only story that I
actually want to talk about today which
is that Barbie is great I saw the Barbie
movie yesterday Ben is completely wrong
a lot of
a lot of conservatives mostly who
haven't seen the movie are wrong to
think it's terrible and woke
the movie is splitting the right I've
noticed that a lot of the conservative
traditional kind of Hardcore
right-wingers really like Barbie and a
lot of the I don't know more libertarian
or center-right-minded people don't like
Barbie we'll get into not even the
politics of it we'll just get into why
Greta Gerwig is a genius director then
we'll get into some other stories too we
also have a lawyer for president Trump
who I think is going to call in to to
just lay out some of the charges in this
case this really dropped out of nowhere
yesterday we'll get to that
one of the potential punishments here
is death
they want to kill him
it's not just they want to undermine his
campaign in 2016 and spy on him and tap
Trump Tower it's not just they want to
impeach him over some nonsense it's not
even just they want to get him to drop
out of the presidential race or they
want to even put him behind bars they
want to kill him they want him dead they
would dance in the streets if this man
died and they would gleefully kill him
this according to 18 U.S codes section
one of the charges here is conspiracy
against rights and includes a penalty of
up to 10 years in federal prison but it
says this if death results from The Acts
committed in violation of this section
or if such acts include kidnapping or an
attempt to kidnap aggravated sexual
abuse or an attempt to commit aggravated
sexual abuse or any attempt to kill they
shall be fined under this title or
imprisoned for any term of years or for
life or both
or maybe sentenced to death so
you might say well look it's just one
potential uh punishment involved in just
one of the charges here and it's only if
anyone dies if death results from these
acts committed but the Liberals have
been arguing since day one that Trump is
responsible for death on January 6th and
the way that they made that argument is
first they just lied and they said that
police officers died because the
pro-trump mob killed them on January 6th
that is a complete lie it never happened
uh the the newspapers had to correct the
story there is one death that did occur
though
ironically the only death from political
violence on January 6 was the death of a
trump supporter killed by a
trigger-happy cop at the Capitol
nevertheless you read 18 USC section 241
you say well all right death did result
from The Acts allegedly committed by
Trump here again the notion that he he
committed these acts is absolutely
laughable
but they've made it this far guys
they impeached him twice but they
impeached him over this they are
bringing so far what
three separate indictments three
separate batches of indictments against
him they're gonna have a lot more to
come
and they want to kill him they want to
kill him they mean business this is
forget about Trump for a second this is
the payoff of the media constantly lying
sometimes people ask why why are the
media constantly telling these small
lies about people
they did it to me earlier this year
remember I went to CPAC I said that for
the good of society especially for the
good of the poor people who fall and
pray to this confusion
the whole ideology at every level
could not have been clearer what I was
talking about they accused me of
genocide they libled me they actually
had to change the headlines I think
because their lawyers called them but
why tell a lie like that what's the
what's the end goal of that
the purpose of telling these small lies
Trump incited people to violence Trump
killed people for whatever whatever
nonsense it's so obvious is so that
they get the payoff
later on later on when they're building
this whole case and it's just faded into
memory what happened on January 6th oh I
heard I heard there was a lot of
violence I heard the pro-trump people
killed people okay that's fine it
justifies it this is why president Trump
is using this campaign line uh which is
I think one of his most effective ones
he says look they're not come after me
they're coming after you they're not
indicting me they're indicting you you
know they're not indicting me they're
indicting you I just happen to be
standing in their way that's all it is
but what you
want you thank you
what you're witnessing is a continuation
of the single greatest Witch Hunt of all
time
this is prosecutorial misconduct and his
primary purpose is to steal another
election
they're all
in a very coordinated attack trying to
take away our election of 2024 they
rigged the presidential election of 2020
we're not going to allow them to rig the
presidential election of 2024.
it's a great line he's tested this out
before and it's true even if you hate
the guy I think you have to recognize
the line is true why are they going
after Trump is it because he kept
classified documents
no we know it's not that because lots of
other politicians in both parties and
especially the Democrats have done that
the OJ doesn't go after them is it
because he incited people to Riot
even let's say you think he did that
it's obviously not for that the
Democrats have openly called for
violence against Republicans for years
now Maxine Waters go to their homes
where their children sleep push back on
them Hillary Clinton don't be civil with
Republicans Eric Holder the list goes on
and on and on and then the Democrats
actually did it for eight months
straight they burned the country down
see to shining sea so it's not that
what is it is it because he where are
the other stupid charges against him
oh they said that he he manhandled a
woman in a Bergdorf Goodmans which was
completely Preposterous uh really you
want to bring that up we're talking
about the Democratic party of of uh Bill
Clinton and Bob Menendez and actually
Joe Biden if we're talking about these
kinds of allegations no I don't think so
what is it is it because he made uh an
in-kind contribution to his own campaign
allegedly through this porn star payoff
whatever are you kidding me you want to
talk about dodgy campaign contributions
the Democrat the Democrats are going to
accuse us of that pot calling the kettle
black no it's just not it's none of
those things it's because Donald Trump
represents a populist conservative
traditional nationalist strain on the
American right it's a strain that the
libs thought they had neutered for about
50 years and they hadn't it came back
again and they're going to throw
everything at him they're not indicting
him they're indicting you you might even
think that he's a deeply imperfect
representative of you you might not even
like the guy he represents you in the
mind of the Liberals okay we've got
an attorney for the president on the
line to help explain this indictment
very very quickly uh Jared Roberts of
binal Law Group who is a zealous
litigator I hope extremely zealous so
that he can win this case Jared thank
you for coming on the show
hey thanks for having me Michael uh just
to clarify uh not not litigating uh not
an attorney of in this case specifically
I'm representing the president in other
cases currently but do have some insight
uh for this one this case just
cropped up about 12 hours ago so I'm
sure the dust is still settling on this
uh what's going on in this case and
what's and and broadly what's going on
with the Trump's defense against the
seven billion indictments that are
coming down before 2024.
say you were just talking about why
they're bringing these indictments how I
view it is the president president Trump
is looking great in polling in recent
polls and that the left is honestly
terrified that they're going to lose to
him again and that they're going to lose
power because they know what's going to
happen when President Trump gets back
into office that they're all going to
lose their jobs and so now they're in
full panic mode and you look at the
charges that were brought against
President Trump yesterday and
they're really just Preposterous charges
I mean a lot of them involve the First
Amendment first of all covers the
majority of what president Trump did on
January 6th the president had a right to
petition the government that's within
the first amendment so to charge the
president with a civil rights charge for
using his first amendment I mean that
opens up the statue into a point where a
court could even find that down the road
to be unconstitutionally vague the same
can be said with the charge regarding
interference with an official proceeding
all he did was engage in the in election
contest as a candidate and as a
president and saying that that's a crime
I mean this is a statute that the doj
loves to use all the time and now this
could really hamper the doj's efforts
elsewhere if this statute becomes so
broad that a court rules the
unconstitutional so I mean what we're
seeing here is Jack Smith is desperate
and he's really trying to stretch the
law to create something when there's
nothing in there so of all the legal
threats I agree in my untutored view
looking at this indictment this one
seems particularly weak at least legally
though politically it seems a bit
stronger because unlike the documents
case which is being tried in Florida a
generally friendlier state with a
friendlier judge this is being tried in
DC a less friendly district with a much
less friendly judge so politically I
guess it could be kind of risky even if
the charges are flimsy of all the
charges that Trump is looking at past
present and future what do you think if
any pose a significant threat to the
campaign or to the man's freedom
I've reviewed all the charges analyze
them and I mean there's nothing there
for any of them obviously the most risky
one is going to DC uh Tanya Truckin is
not the greatest drawing that the
president could have gotten as a judge
she's a former colleague of Hunter Biden
actually
and not a good sign no so it's not I
mean although these are the weakest
charges that are brought they're all
weak but these charges especially are
Preposterous this is a very unfavorable
jurisdiction and there's a reason that
Jack Smith is pulling president Trump
out of his home District into DC because
he's looking for an easy win and he's
really willing to stretch the rule of
law no matter the cost do you looking
down the pike now before 2024 you you've
got the documents case scheduled for May
20th I think it is you've got this new
case coming up uh how many of these are
actually going to go to trial before the
election
I can't tell you the answer to that
um we're currently involved in uh
majority civil litigation however I can
tell you that I
judge Trucking especially is going to
want to move this case along very
quickly however there's going to be a
lot of motions practice and things are
going to be drawn out I mean president
Trump has great lawyers that will be
representing him in DC and one motion
that I think will be interesting that
could be brought is under uh the
impeachment judgment Clause president
Trump was already acquitted for these
charges and what I think that emotion
under this uh would definitely be
beneficial whether or not
judge chucking honors it or not that's a
different story but it's important to
remember that President Trump has
already been acquitted so that's
an interesting point so you're saying
just as for any ordinary citizen you
can't be tried twice for the same thing
if you tried and you're acquitted they
can't just bring you to trial again for
the exact same charges what you're
saying is we already had a trial here it
was called the impeachment trial and
Trump was acquitted he wasn't convicted
and so okay bye you know this this is
over
in theory I think that can be the case
yeah I mean the Constitution lays out
the if Congress views the president
exceeded
his duties and went outside of that the
only remedy against the president is the
is impeachment they went through that
process president Trump was acquitted
and now to bring him again on these new
charges is absurd all right uh that's
it's a little glimmer of hope there uh
Jared I have to let you go there thank
you so much for making the time to hop
on we will uh probably have to have you
back as as these uh indictments just
keep rolling in that seems by the week
thank you very much for coming on I
appreciate it Michael thank you all
right
now
speaking of good news that's a little
bit of glimmer of hope and I've got some
good news for a good meal that can come
to you from
good ranchers right now go to
goodranches.com use promo code nulls you
know I love anything made with top of
the line quality for meat that's good
ranchers the only thing missing from
good ranchers I was saying this sweet
little Elise about a month ago was a
pork box was
because if you ask they deliver good
ranchers has just launched their Prime
pork 100 American pork that is
Steakhouse quality this new pork box
comes with bone-in and boneless pork
chops sausage smoked brats and more plus
right now you will get 30 bucks off with
my code Knowles kwles at
goodranchers.com on their site you can
explore their All-American cuts of prime
pork prime beef better than organic
chicken options I eat good ranchers
constantly I just love it it the quality
is out of this world I especially love
the rib eyes I was never a huge rib eye
guy the rib eye one of the best I've
ever had they're Burgers I've had a
billion burgers in my life probably the
best hamburgers I've ever had in my
entire life
the quality is just out of this world
the prices cannot be beat and right now
if you go to goodranchers.com use code
nulls you will get 30 bucks off any box
promo code Knowles kwles
goodranchers.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered now I want to
talk about something that actually
matters forget about the presidential
race the political order the direction
of our country
I saw barbie yesterday they asked me to
see Barbie
the daily wire asked me to see Barbie
because
Ben talked about it and Ben's very harsh
critique of Barbie made national news
and so before the backstage show last
night which is where I gave most of my
view on Barbie I won't belabor it too
much now uh
they said okay see it and see if you
agree with Banner if you disagree with
Ben because it's probably going to come
up on the show
I said Okay meet sweet little Elisa we
go watch the movie
I intentionally
did not watch or read any reviews before
the movie I saw that Ben hated it
so I saw the little clip of him throwing
the Barbies and setting them on fire in
the trash can I saw that some other
people hated it and I saw that some
other people liked it and I noticed
without reading any reviews or see
watching any reviews I saw that some
people and some social media accounts
that I really like and admire liked
Barbie one of my favorite all-time
Twitter accounts Edmund smirk uh
eudaimonia for a very sharp fella you
dimonius girlfriend Shuan head who's a
leftist but she has interesting takes I
noticed they all kind of liked it I
noticed that my friend Brett Cooper here
liked it but then a number of my other
buddies on the right up to it including
Ben Shapiro they hated Barbie so I
wanted to go in with a totally fresh
slate not colored by anyone else's views
I hadn't even really maybe I watched the
trailer I don't even really remember
watching the trailer and I go in
it's great
I was primed to like it because
one it's always fun to disagree with Ben
but you know sometimes Ben and I agree
and two because Greta Gerwig did a great
job with ladybird her movie that came
out in 2017 I thought was really really
excellent so I already had this sense
that greteger wig is not some just crazy
radical who gets everything wrong Lady
Bird was a very conservative movie and
so I I watched it
guys from the very beginning it's not
even particularly ambiguous that Barbie
is a conservative movie the short
version of it is it opens up with this
this homage to 2001 A Space Odyssey it's
these little girls playing with their
baby dolls and they're having a nice
time then Barbie comes in as this icon
of feminist progress and the girls start
killing their babies
which if that doesn't sum up feminism I
don't know what does then they go into
Barbie land which is a feminist Utopia
and they show all the different types of
Barbies Dr Barbie president Barbie this
Barbie that Barbie then they get to
pregnant Barbie and the narrator comes
in and says oh yeah that one was
discontinued we can't have pregnant
Barbie here in Barbie land but you know
a woman can be anything but you can't be
pregnant
already that's a very strongly two very
strongly anti-feminist moments clearly
intentional clearly very precise then
you go on through Barbie land
everything's fine it's all about Barbie
all the men are just simps all the Ken's
are just kind of simp
Cox who just do whatever Barbie wants
and they have no identity outside of
Barbie and then then something starts to
crack
Barbie becomes dissatisfied with this
eternal present Barbie starts to wonder
about death he says wait Am I Ever Gonna
Die what's time what's progress what's
love what's Consciousness she becomes
self-conscious and then this Guru
feminist Barbie weirdo Barbie this is
all spoiler alerts by the way so if you
if you do want to watch the movie maybe
skip a few seconds here uh Guru feminist
Barbie comes in and says okay you can
choose the red pill or the blue pill you
can choose either the high heels
pretty high heels or you can choose
Birkenstocks you know of reality and and
so Barbie says Okay I want the pretty
high heels
I want the blue pill
and this is really
significant I think feminist Barbie goes
oh no I was presenting you with the
illusion of a choice but you don't
really have a choice you have to do the
gritty awful terrible
you know Birkenstock thing which is
reminiscent I think of Simone de
Beauvoir the French feminist who in a
debate with Betty Friedan once said we
can't give women a real choice
yeah we can we pretend that women have a
choice to either stay at home or go out
to the workplace but they can't really
have that choice because if women have
the choice to stay home and live a
traditional life too many of them are
going to choose family and children and
husbands so they have to basically be
forced out into the workplace and that's
what you see in Barbie land so then
Barbie goes into the real world
and Ken goes with her and Ken says wow
the real world is a patriarchy oh man
this is great and this is where uh Ken
joins the manosphere which we'll get to
in one second first though
talking about restoring balance to the
Sexes to our political order you need to
restore balance to your body with
balance of nature right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure you
are getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day through
balance of Nature's Advanced cold vacuum
process the vitamins minerals and
phytonutrients of the fruits and veggies
are preserved so that you can get that
vital nutrition in each capsule balance
of nature is a whole food supplement
with no additives fillers extracts
synthetics pesticides or added sugar
pure fruits and veggies are the only
things they put in their capsules
balance of nature send a bunch of their
products down to the studio for our team
to try and these jackals these absolute
hyenas rip them all apart before I can
even have the opportunity to get mine
it's my only complaint about the whole
thing make sure you go right now for a
limited time this summer two balance of
nature when you become a preferred
customer they are throwing in a free
fruit and veggies travel set and giving
an additional 25 bucks off your first
order go to balanceofnature.com promo
code Knowles kwles for a free travel set
and 25 bucks off your first order is a
preferred customer that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
Barbie and Ken go into the real world
and they see that the real world is not
controlled by all these feminist girl
bosses the real world is controlled by
men the people in the c-suites in the
really public positions of power they're
all men
now
that's not the end of the story
because
what one begins to notice is
the the people who are actually driving
The Narrative of this movie forward it's
not the men the men are kind of goofy
it's these women in private little
actions a woman who's drawing a Barbie a
woman who's having thoughts about Barbie
is actually the one who's changing the
world and driving the whole plot forward
and then we find out by the end
that the the woman who invented Barbie
or that the person rather who invented
Barbie is a woman this woman played by
Rhea Perlman and she has a very
significant line here
when Barbie finds her and says hey wait
women work at this Mattel company too
women women work in this real world too
Ria perlman's character this god-like
Creator character who who built Barbie
she leans in she says women do more than
work here women do more than work
feminism tells you that a woman going
out and working and having a job is the
only thing that matters it's the most
important thing the conservatives will
tell you what are you talking about
going out and having a job it's fine but
there's so so much more important
there are so many more important things
in life having children having a family
being The Hand That Rocks the Cradle is
the hand that rules the world
that line very hard to see how that line
is not intentional anyway Ken gets
radicalized he says wait a second in
this real world it's The Men Who call
the shots not the women so they go back
and Ken becomes this uh nanosphere kind
of guy you know he has the the the Kaza
Kaza Bunga I forget what he calls it but
it's kind of a funny name for the Ken
house now and in the kendam he dresses
up in this really peacocking way but he
doesn't know how to be a real man
and this
I'll skip over some stuff in the middle
uh I wish I could go on for hours about
Barbie but we don't have time for it uh
by the end
Ken realizes no I just Barbie all I want
is you even when I'm peacocking and
bragging all I really want I just feel
like I'm only Built for you and I'm just
here to serve you and I have no identity
outside of you and Barbie doesn't choose
Ken this is one of the reasons why the
conservatives have been saying this is a
woke movie because Barbie and Ken should
end up together right no no
Barbie land is a feminist Utopia
it seems in theory kind of nice I guess
it's really just a fantasy for little
children but it's not something's deeply
wrong here
Ken is a product of feminism and so when
Barbie says hey Ken you've got it before
before you just try to throw yourself at
me and we get married or whatever you
need to figure out who you are because
Ken is not the big Alpha gigachad
traditional man leading his family he's
a product of feminism he's kind of a
simp he's kind of a he doesn't
he's not the kind of man that a woman
actually wants to marry so when she says
you've got to figure out who you are
this is a message for boys who are
raised in this feminist world that
unfortunately we live in it's it's not a
knock on the boys this is how they were
raised but they've got to figure out how
to be a man
not just going going along to get along
with the feminist world and not just
reacting against it in some Childish way
that doesn't actually build them up as
proper men you've got to figure out how
to be a man in the real sense of things
so then
Barbie chooses to leave this is another
example a lot of the conservatives seem
to think that Barbie land is considered
the good place and the real world is
considered the bad place Barbie land
feminist good real world patriarchy bad
Barbie chooses the real world
the Barbie land is is the bad place
the Barbie land that's why there are all
these jokes about patriarchy she says
the word patriarchy like a dozen times
in there that's a joke that's a punch
line we know it's a punchline because
the ray of Pearlman Creator character at
the end admits at the end of the movie
she says oh yeah people in order to cope
with the ambigu ambiguous nature of this
Fallen World you know in order to cope
with the craziness of this world we just
make things up we make things up like
Barbie we make things up like patriarchy
does this mean we make things up like
the actual structure of the patriarchy
that controls everything or we make
things up like the concept of the
patriarchy just like the concept of
Barbie
I think it's the latter and Greta Gerwig
an interviews has said everything in
this movie is intended to operate on two
levels the movie has
clear Christian imagery I mean she's
admitted that herself credit card said
in interviews a lot of this comes from
her Catholic School upbringing
even though I don't think Gregory is a
practicing Catholic that's how she was
educated you see it throughout all of
her movies and then to me the the part
where gretiger really shows her hand is
at the very end of the movie after she
admits the patriarchy yeah it's just
that's like a fake make-believe concept
to cope with the difficulties of the
world
Barbie's happy vision of the future
which is why she chooses reality which
is supposedly a patriarchy is not being
a girl boss and going to work at some
widget Factory it's motherhood
it's family even the mother and daughter
in the in the real world which is a
driving theme in the film it's not even
just like a single mother who's angry at
the world she's married she's in a kind
of traditional relationship even though
her husband
in the real world is kind of a Ken
he's he's been he's been castrated by
the feminist culture as well so there's
a problem to work out there in the real
world
and the things that women complain about
in the real world and in Barbie land
their their complaints
about what feminism has done not about
what tradition has done
we're expected to be girl bosses we're
expected to have jobs the final scene
Barbie walks in you think it's going to
be the apotheosis of the whole feminist
journey in the movie and she's going to
go get her job in the real world no
they say what are you here for ma'am she
goes I'm here to see
my gynecologist
which is a surface level joke about how
Barbie dolls don't have genitalia it's a
deeper joke which ties in with the
entire thesis of the movie and every
theme from the very first shot of the
movie which is oh no what really matters
here
motherhood one of the lines one of the
key lines from this exasperated real
world woman talking in Barbie land she
says I I want a Barbie I don't want a
Barbie that's the president I want a
Barbie that's a doctor I don't want to I
want a Barbie that says it's okay just
to be a mom
that's that's one of the realizations
this woman had woman has during the
movie
Gerwig is great now I know some people
say Michael you're reading too deeply
into this first of all Grady Gerwig
literally says in interviews hey you
should realize there there is a double
meaning here to the movie as there was
in ladybird but first but I guess my
other answer to that is
um
what do you what do you think is more
likely that rediger wig just
accidentally
fills all of her movies with these very
precise deeply meaningful
points from beginning to end of all of
her movies
or that she's doing it intentionally
or at least artistically
it's not just an accident it's not just
oh yeah you're reading a little too much
into every single moment of her movie
that's coherent
the the argument against Barbie to say
it's so super woke the best argument
people can muster is oh it's an
incoherent movie I don't think it's
incoherent I think it's extremely
coherent I've explained a little bit of
how coherent it is uh what's more likely
seems to me also it's just a nice piece
of filmmaking because it's fun and you
know the performances are good and
they're singing and dancing and it's
very colorful
that's a good movie guys it's a good
movie
really
I don't I don't think I'm allowed to
remain a heterosexual married man with
children if I talk about Barbie for even
one second longer but
I left the movie more optimistic about
the culture there are a lot of people
out here Drew made this point last night
at Backstage there were a lot of young
women who wouldn't call themselves
traditionally conservative or Christian
or right-wing or whatever who are waking
up and recognizing feminism is really
bad people who in recent years would
have called themselves left-wing
feminists liberals whatever who are
turning against birth control who are
turning against the hookup culture who
want to get married who want to have
children who want to do normal things
okay
I think this would be a sign of those
times
speaking of feminism
while people are turning against
feminism
the
liberal media are embracing it all the
more
Washington Post
has just run a story
about
this tragedy of a teen couple woman gets
pregnant
and they're not able to abort the kids
not able to kill the children
so the Washington Post runs the story
not just on the couple now facing this
dilemma
but years later
say an abortion ban made them teen
parents this is life two years later and
it goes on to very lengthy piece written
by Carolyn Kitchener and this this story
talks about how this this 19 year old
has twin daughters and you know she
wasn't this girl wasn't ready to start a
family and she and her now husband are
trying to work it out and but it's
really hard and because the the nearest
abortion clinic was 13 hours away they
didn't kill the babies because Roe v
Wade was overruled and so now uh now
she's got these kids
tone of the story though
seems to me is that this is a bad thing
oh no they can't where they're having a
tough tough go of it and the husband and
wife don't really get along very well
now they got these two kids they've got
to deal with
this is pretty ghoulish stuff I think
the effect of the story is to be
pro-life because I think normal people
reading this story are going to say well
hold on Washington Post
are you lamenting that these cute little
two-year-olds are alive you're
complaining about that what kind of
stone cold psychos are you
but I don't know I think at least the
editors who greenlit this
actually were sincerely making that
point oh look at this tragedy
this is the consequence of overruling
Roe v Wade these cute little girls have
to live
and now your parents have to take care
of them when they could have just
murdered them isn't that a tragedy
normal people
are convinced of babies Humanity
when they see it this is why if a woman
is considering abortion and she goes in
and has an ultrasound
she is overwhelmingly likely to keep the
baby not to kill the baby
she doesn't have an ultrasound it's
anybody's game but if she sees the
ultrasound this is why a lot of
conservative legislation says okay if
you're going to have an abortion if we
can't
Outlaw abortion you at least have to
have an ultrasound to see the baby first
because that's going to save the baby
the vast majority of the time normal
people when they see a baby are
convinced of the baby's humanity and
know that it's wrong to kill that baby
some psychos like serial killers and
deeply demented people and journalists
they're not they're not convinced of the
baby's Humanity or they just don't care
shows you yet again a big Chasm big gap
between the liberal ruling class The
Establishment and the government and the
Academia and the media
and the people big big
difference here and I think once again
accidentally when normal people see this
thing
they're going to have the uh they're
going to draw the opposite conclusion
that the media want us to draw now
speaking of liberals mistreating
children there is some positive news
from the Biden front
which we'll get to in one second first
though the libs believe that good
intentions absolve them of bad behavior
this type of thinking is quite
hypocritical of course and wrong but
being a good person requires more effort
than just trying to Signal your own
virtue that is for sure you got to be
self-aware for starters there are more
attributes you need to cultivate many of
them you probably haven't thought about
that's why you got to watch the final
episode of prageru's master's program
streaming on daily wire plus and
prageru's master's program Dennis Prager
has gathered 40 years worth of wisdom
he's sharing it a wide number of
subjects how to be a good person is this
week's episode Dennis also covers the
differences between men and women the
consequences of secularism and much more
remember the world wants to make you
woke Dennis Prager wants to make you
wise priorities Masters program does
just that all episodes are now available
do not wait go to dailywireplus.com to
become a member and watch prageru's
master's program today
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Abraham Cardenas 13.
says Libs don't vote for Trump he'll get
us into world war three five years later
we must get into World War III to save a
country that I can't make out on a map
so so true you have liberals and
squishes on the right saying that we
need to do what we manage to avoid for
the entirety of the Cold War we need to
enter into a hot direct conflict with a
nuclear former superpower over a
Thousand-Year geopolitical conflict of a
place in Eastern Europe that the vast
majority of these people couldn't point
to on a map
that's what we're hearing
Le it was amazing how right after that
Russian invasion of of Ukraine
how many Eastern European foreign policy
experts there were
on the liberal left it's just amazing
how quickly that I thought you had to
study things no just overnight
overnight really really good point and
now getting back to liberals mistreating
children
Joe Biden has finally acknowledged his
granddaughter that he has been refusing
to accept for four years now Joe Biden
has very officiously intentionally left
his seventh grandchild out of any
acknowledgment at the White House in
public comments but he issued a
statement on a Friday night because
presumably this was polling really
terribly and he said okay we're going to
start acknowledging our granddaughter
now and he's now sat down on a podcast
and said as much in person
I have uh seven grandkids uh four of
them all five of them old enough to talk
on the phone you know every day I either
text them or call them
so it used to be
I've got six grandkids until like a week
ago I've been I've had six grandkids I
talk to them every day now it's I have
seven grandkids five of them old enough
to talk on the phone this is a way to
say I don't talk to my seventh
grandchild I I wouldn't even acknowledge
her until a week ago but yeah now I'm
acknowledging her why because the
Liberals are finally turning on this was
pulling terribly Maureen Dowd at the New
York Times came out and said you seem
heartless Joe Biden you have to
acknowledge his granddaughter and then a
couple weeks later he finally
acknowledges her uh totally cynical
totally transparent I guess good for the
little girl at least that her
grandfather isn't being he was at least
bullied into not being such a deadbeat
cruel degenerate but it's really really
a little a little late better late than
never I guess in any case speaking of
Joe Biden Trump and Biden are tied
nationally right now
uh there's a new new poll out this is by
New York Times Siena College so you
can't call it a conservative poll Trump
Biden
43-43. uh what's the breakdown the
breakdown is much more interesting than
the Top Line National numbers
Trump is leading among white voters by
10 points
it's a decent lead
Biden is leading among black voters by
59 points
Biden is leading among Hispanic voters
by three points
so
the the other interesting aspect when we
break this down is that Trump has more
support among his base than Biden has
among his Trump in a huge field with 10
candidates
has more support in the GOP than Joe
Biden who is the incumbent and
theoretically should be running on a
post he's got Bobby Kennedy's running
against him then Biden has as an
incumbent among his space really really
pathetic for Biden and really bad news
for the other GOP candidates
Trump in this contested race has more of
a lock on his party than Biden does in
practically speaking an uncontested race
uh that's a terrible signal for
the other Republicans in the race but
what is the message broadly for the GOP
here the message for the GOP is that the
GOP needs to focus on driving the white
vote
Trump's got a 10-point lead
uh okay that that's fine he's got to
increase that lead Joe Biden is a 59
point lead among black voters and black
voters make up a much much smaller
percentage of the electorate than white
voters do
so any one or two point gain among
among white voters is gonna would be
worth five times that among black voters
and the GOP I know we want to focus on
the black vote because the Democrats
constantly disingenuously accuse us of
being racist or whatever and I'd love it
if all the black voters came out to the
GOP that would be totally wonderful but
it's a matter of resources and effort
it's just a pure numbers game it is much
smarter for the GOP to focus on on
increasing Trump's lead among the white
vote and the Hispanic vote too don't
forget uh 12 13 of the population is
black 20 percent of the American
population is Hispanic 60 is white so
you're going to get your highest returns
by focusing on the white vote your
second highest returns focusing on the
Hispanic vote which is much more
competitive much more winnable for the
GOP and then it'd be great to win over
all the black voters but the vast
majority have not come over yet and
we've got limited resources limited time
focus on the whites and Hispanics if you
want to increase your likelihood of
winning the race speaking of white
people and black people some troubling
news out of South Africa
a member of parliament in South Africa
leader of the economic freedom fighters
party Julius malema took to a rally on
Saturday and called explicitly for the
murder of whites in the country
[Applause]
this is a full Stadium totally packed
with people
the poor kill the boa
boa is a descendant of the white Dutch
who said himself
[Applause]
kill the white farmers
so this is troubling and you probably
haven't heard about this story because
it's being shut up in the media Elon
Musk is trying to call attention to it
because he's South African a great
African-American leader Elon Musk Elon
said they're openly pushing for genocide
of white people in South Africa Cyril
ramaphosa who's the leader of South
Africa why do you say nothing why is the
leader of South Africa successor to
Mandela supposed to be so peaceful and
wonderful and kumbayan uniting everybody
he's saying nothing while a member of
parliament in South Africa is calling
for the genocide of whites for being
white
and the media are basically saying
nothing too
why because it's politically incorrect
even to mention this you're not you're
not allowed even if
a sitting politician
sitting office holder comes out and says
we want to murder all the white people
genocide all the whites
if you especially if you're a white
person if you call any attention to that
you're the one who's transgressed that's
a little Politically Incorrect you might
be a little bit racist
if you say that the white people
shouldn't be genocided let's just not
touch it it's a little it's a little
awkward president of South Africa is not
going to mention it
the media where they're not going to
talk about it
so reviled are white people by the
political establishment
that even when prominent politicians
in office
say kill whitey murder them all
you can't don't that's not let's just
let him do it let's just you know
actually didn't those Farmers have it
coming to them
you know the descendants of the Dutch
you settled there hundreds of years ago
didn't they're kind of
I think they have it coming
so we've talked about whites we've
talked about blacks we've talked about
Hispanics we should talk about the
Japanese this will be my little tease
you know I'm such a tease I have there's
a guy there's a Japanese guy
who just spent fourteen thousand dollars
to dress up as a border collie he got a
really nice Lassie costume
this is not if you think of there's a
sexual fetish called free freism where
you dress up like anthropomorphic
animals this isn't that this guy looks
like Lassie it's yummy doesn't really
look like Lassie you can still tell he's
a dude in a dog suit he's still
something soft but it's a very good
costume you can see why he would spend
fourteen thousand dollars for this if
this were his King in any case
I guess we're gonna have to hold off and
get to it tomorrow there's much to be
said about this in our culture of
transition there's much to be said
for those
canines and we'll get to that
tomorrow the rest of the show continues
now it's woke Wednesday you don't want
to miss it become a member use code
Knowles Kennedy WLA as a check out for
two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you foreign